allora oggi nuovo boxing tiger alle
buste
ho comprato tutte le buste sorpresa di
tiger e allora queste piccoli ne sono da
3 euro invece queste più grandi 5 euro
in più c'è scritto che in queste cose a
5 euro il valore che c'è dentro è di 10
euro
in teoria sì sono cose di un valore più
alto
non so se per queste lo stesso perché
non ce lo aggiungo niente però la voce
magari proveremo a calcolarlo in base a
quello che si è dentro speriamo di sì
quelli questione gusto sempre se si
travestono super curioso di vedere cosa
troveremo dentro voi nei commenti dovete
dirci qual è la busta che vi è piaciuta
di più in base alle sorprese e quali la
sorpresa che vi è piaciuta di più qui
como dove rate questo video fino alla
fine la sua con belle like se volete che
prendiamo altre sorprese o altre cose
così gli ottici pure cos'altro prendere
di cos'altro fare l'unboxing del
prossimo video per due grandi sono a
tema questo è il tema garzetti e questo
tema cucina cambio cucina ma anche
perché così noi o qui perché ci ha fatto
né faccio tutto io siamo grandi si può
scegliere il tema delle sorprese se la
cera gadget cucina in bagno e cari
cancelleria perforazioni a casa
se queste non c'è nessun tema mettetevi
comodi volevo innanzitutto far vedere
due penne che ho comprato che mi
piacciono tantissimo perché mi ricordano
sailor moon
quindi è una penna una bella mano una
penna che la strina e una penna con la
luna costa ma solamente un euro ruda e
in più ma gli esperti luminose sono
bellissime sono proprio carinissime 1 e
blu con sé un rota e le pene sono che
non scrive scrive vabbè devo scrivere un
po prima
comunque è una penna nera sono troppo
carine a fianco la prima busta ne ho
aiutate voi allora prima volta questa
busta verde prendiamo subito cosa c'è
dentro bus avere con la scritta gialla
allora abbiamo scartata solamente due
oggetti o ex pip per i capelli che al me
non piace ma è comunque utile la pinza
per i capelli per quando esiste il
sistema i capelli e costruttiva valore
di staccarmi questa cosa 57
infatti questa massimo un euro questa
pizza forse 50 centesimi anche fatta un
po male però almeno dritte rata
poi secondo oggetto quando siamo per
decorare uno slam
oddio che cos'è questa cosa c'è scritto
è un annuncio per il caminetto
così come nel caso ci posso credere
crediamo bello ma chi è che può servire
una funzionari cabine per andare a c'è
il sensore tipo per andare al bagno di
notte perché si prevede comunque
accendere la luce se non vedi dove fai
così i maschietti prendono la birra e
sanno dov'è allora matera avanti le
batterie più seri vedi c'è il sensore di
cuori il sensore commesso fuori volta
che sono andato quando tu entri in bagno
lui ti accende la luce attiva e ti fa
fare le due cosette del tritone alla
luce lì senza accendere la miccia
christoph arrabbiato non so per cosa
potrei votarla se sì puntare per
qualcosa fa alla cantinetta questo
quanto può valere 29 centesimi
diciamo che il valore di 3 euro
così così era meglio comparso un gelato
allora però la prima volta non ci ha
convinto per niente quindi è bocciata
voi cosa ne pensate
avere quella maglietta con la scritta
rossa parliamo seriamente
avete qualcosa sì però spero sia dal
cibo no allora cos'è il cibo dentro e
che con la bambina
ok ci sono tante cose bellissime
cominciamo da questa è questa quella più
più carrierone in porta trucchi e mi è
misurato aspetta ventola logic nello
specchio anno scusa non porta rossetto
non avevo mai visto un porta rossetto
scusa la domanda nei rossetti non si
buttano nel box almeno così non lo butti
nella borsa buone gare per i nostri
preziosi se non si devono rovinare
ultimamente ha esortato testa non è
anche io sinceramente rivedete avete mai
visto un porta rossetto nei commenti e
utilità meno uno questo quanto sarà
costato lo stesso 56 insieme forse un
euro ma silvio con rimasto staccato no
non escono scollato a tutti
no no non era incollato vede che stavano
la foto vuol dire che la loro auto vita
non lo presti ma si everton e con la
doppia faccia
c'è una cosa utilissima che bella
maschera e una maschera così ma è così a
carnevale ve lo ammetto spavento tutti
buoni massima crisi perché veniamo a non
è nemmeno di cotone però questa è che
proprio quelle chimiche cento per cento
l'inimico bellissima perché bisogna
aggiungere l'acqua dentro fressato
spalmarla sul viso ma utile tra la
maschera di tessuto almeno ma vabbè
questa comunque la utiliz 09 come lo
diventerà roberto giorno adesso il nome
che il porto rossetto una macchina di
parlare certo per forza e poi c'è
un'altra cosa
il sale ai sali da bagno solito bagno
alla domanda che buon fine a questo tema
profuma proprio di c'è profumo puzza di
bagno frutta 30 profumando un po la
stanza questo è utile per fare il bagno
che sono nate l'acqua calda e talora
metterlo il sale prima di concerti di
questa brutta sorpresa altre cose un
euro ci porta su tesi mini partite due
forse tre io ma ci sono secondo me
questo e questo sono già molto meglio di
quella di prima camerale per parigi è
stato lucio sapir me lo avete fatto male
male male
sì quindi meglio questa che vestono
monterò sicuramente in sali da bagno
l'amata maschera motori era almeno ci
sono un po più di così c'è scritto sti
forse ticker quindi immagino stica kelly
grafiche ed esce come segni come i
gratta e vinci però non vinci fantastico
perché prima c'è da trattare
qui devo dire che si vanno usati vanno
attaccati sopra un disegno poi si tratta
equa e trasparente così si vede disegni
e utilissimi vestiti quindi così valore
eventi successivi prossimo oggetto sono
dei taglierini da almeno questi sono
utili sono anche carine celeste un euro
anche questi titoli
questa mattina i due poi cosa c'è e cosa
se abbiamo dei workshop takes euro degli
scotch decorativi queste sono carini e
sono anche utili per decorare o per
chiudere i regali da visto mi piacciono
carini si meno male in qualcosa di più
carino stiamo ripetendo poi se
attenzione con una tinta acrilico perché
mera non lo so ma per l'occidente se si
va verde perché sarà farà parte delle
challenge questa qui infatti serve
comunque la tinta acrilico anche per
onorarli di slime però e non era quindi
insomma così così se messe senza s party
con la gonna bianca poi esce questo qui
riesce tutto dai grigioni
che carini queste sono bellissimi ma
sempre per decorarla si dei minis coach
decorativi e sono glitterati vediamo
sono morti ben crollato e adesso ha
scosso allora uno è rosso glitterato
bronzo oro céleste e nero quindi anche
questi sono carini molto questi mediocri
navali per decorare il giornale il
giornale di bordo
sì ma cosa davvero aveva molte più cose
rispetto alle a ma non è che magari
nelle altre erano sbarcate parla ma che
ne hanno chiesti bene che se aveva solo
tre cose questa 2 guarda questa volante
pregio allora questi sono dei bottoni
con dei pezzi di fil di ferro per fare
con fiori con bottoni vedete perché le
aree i fiori che noi sicuramente useremo
per decorare il vero motore di questa
busta fa aveva con sé e direi che questa
è l'unica che valeva effettivamente tre
ore sì perché per 3 euro queste cose ci
sono buone però le altre due
bocciate questa approvata voi invece
cosa ne pensate
perché quelle grandi invece vediamo se
veramente il valore è 10 euro ora ecco
la mia busta
se la busta musa cucina dai superiore
perché perché tra l'altro questa butta
riutilizzabili invece di chiedere nel
supermercato e buste di plastica
riutilizzate queste tutte qua allora
cominciata questa che è incartato loro
sarà una cosa è certa con i pianeti è
enorme
che però può essere utile dai
permetterci che nasce a vederle all
ingresso di inazione la fede è troppo
sostenuto insieme può tornare utile
permetterci che cosa il suo mezzo di
zucchero ma non male questo sì quando
gli utensili ok in 50 centesimi di carta
a questi fazzoletti usati
ci saranno tutti loro hanno aperti
oppure erano realmente di magazzino che
l'hanno verità e ci sono le si chiamano
per stand italiano slot e pro di
pokerclub pratico che si abbraccia la
palla ma anche in questi 50 centesimi
se uno quindi siamo a meno 50
ma cosa c'entra con la cucina a questo
esito forse sono un po confusi dato che
secondo me perché questo frangente
in pratica puoi fare le tue forme poi
posti il ferro da stiro e rimango della
maglietta quindi fare il suo disegno nei
vestiti e non c'entra niente con la
cucina però è carino questo costerà un
euro per 50
siamo a 3 euro grazie al centro ci
scrive dice che le ricette di calamità
queste sono le vignette dignità alle
info rosa e carina però venute
raccontata quindi a bell effetto e del
piccolino e tascabile dai questa è
carina anche se non c'entra con la
cucina è penultima a jaffa sono fatto
parlare per ultimo e penultimo articolo
ma è un portale di quello che fai da te
e centro lucino equa fi tipo che come è
una bacinella pensavo fosse il destino
se diciamo che è una di questi nella
quindi carino anche questo tipo passiamo
la jella facciamo che 2 euro
23 euro 15 euro per il momento da rete
sprecate ma che è di fatto tutte ultimo
è l'ultimo oggetto un orologio minuscolo
accordo di arancia
e magari ancora non attaccarlo numero 1
lettera e un altro è un euro e cinquanta
dai 75 56 7 euro
ok tutto il contenuto della busta fucina
cosa ne pensate
invece la cina per odio che costavano
solamente 5 euro questo forse un'idea
carina e molto bello allora de carlo il
regalo se la sorpresa di mi è piaciuta
di più è stata questa
e son curioso di provarla perché si può
decorare una maglietta e mettere il
proprio disegno questa è la busta gadget
speriamo di trovare qualcosa di carino e
divertente vediamo allora primo oggetto
abbiamo dei palloncini che sono
metallizzati quindi costeggiava mi piace
perché tutti a votare per fare
amo delle bandierine sono bandierine per
le feste quindi per i compleanni
batterie per compleanni molto semplici
di carta zucca bello almeno penso che
sia un cappello che parlano i fiori
esordito cappello a forma di malissimo
dopo vi facciamo vedere come
di testa e un vaso con dei fiori sopra
anche questo mi piace perché non sapete
che noi mettiamo un po se mi ci mettiamo
qualche talento ma né video né
conoscerne anche nella vittoria e quindi
ci metteremo sicuramente questo cappello
in testa io voglio questo mi piace un
piccolo nero non c'è nessuna etichetta è
un cappello statale cioè in pratica è un
cappello da stregone è bellissimo vi
piace un sacco
quindi queste erano tutte le sorprese
della busta gadget
secondo me la sorpresa più bella era
questo fatto questa prima che il gas è
bastato litio
secondo volto avere una sorpresa più
bella e post era anche la busta più
carina se li avevano 5 euro 2 cappelli
già un buon prezzo
se poi vi faccio vedere come ci stanno i
cappelli
c'e troppo questo grazioso soffochino un
amico che se mi volto e poi fiori vitale
si è trasformata in un vaso vitato si
spaccava ora missione così avesse il mio
invece da stregone vi piace un sacco
anche che abbia questa parte dorata
fatta imbottita dell'iscritto e le
stelline dorate mi piace tantissimo
questo cappello proviamo a scambiarsi i
gatti
e bravissimo questo brano divertente
anche se sta bene il cappello da strega
a me porto che circonda la mia maglia
marrone destra che ora quindi da
strapazzo confermo remato sapere se vi
sono piaciute queste buste se volete che
ne compriamo altri vediamo altre
sorprese reale secondo me le sorprese
più belle sono state appunto questi due
cappelli e cene a qualche salto che ci
ha sorpreso quello che puoi mettere le
decorazioni nella maglietta e per le
aree secondo voi invece stile ticini
commenti secondo voi qual era la
sorpresa più bella lasciato un ex volete
altre a un boxing e allora mi lascia un
po a 4 castelli e scooter per via delle
nostre shopping unboxing di casa quella
che preferite